ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND THE JOB
THAT WE WON'T OR CAN'T DO.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
A BIG IMMIGRATION DEBATE IS
UNDERWAY ON CAPITOL HILL.
MITCH McCONNELL IS SAYING YOU
ONLY HAVE ONE WEEK TO DO THE
WHOLE THING.
I'M TELLING YOU, WATCHING THIS
THING, THE SAME OLD OPEN BORDERS
AND SUSPECTS ARE IT AGAIN.
FRONT AND CENTER IS
SENATOR DICK DURBIN.
HE TOOK TO THE SENATE FLOOR
YESTERDAY TO REPEATED THAT
TEDIOUS TROPE THAT YOU AMERICANS
ARE JUST TOO LAZY OR UNWILLING
TO DO THE JOBS THAT ONLY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WILL DO.
>> GO TO THE LOCAL MEAT
PROCESSING PLANT AND WATCH WHAT
COMES OUT OF THAT PLANT AT
QUITTING TIME.
HISPANICS AND AFRICANS TAKING
WHAT ARE PRETTY TOUGH, DIRTY,
ROUGH JOBS BECAUSE OTHERS DON'T
WANT THEM.
NOT MANY OF US SAY TO OUR SONS
AND DAUGHTERS, I'M HOPING THEY
WILL, WHEN YOU DECIDED TO PICK
FRUIT FOR A LIVING.
YOU HARDLY EVER HEAR THAT
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S HARD
BACKBREAKING WORK AND IMMIGRANTS
DO THE WORK.
>> Laura: THAT IS SO OFFENSIVE
ON SO MANY LEVELS, WE CAN SPEND
AN HOUR DEBUNKING IT AND
ANALYZING IT.
FROM MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE,
MY BROTHERS, MY MOTHER AND I DID
ALL OF THESE JOBS.
WE DID MANUAL LABOR, FRUIT
PICKING, PAPER ROUTE, RESTAURANT
WORK, MY MOTHER WAITED TABLES
INTO HER EARLY 70s.
IF SHE WERE ALIVE, I THINK ABOUT
HER A LOT, I THINK SHE WOULD
PROBABLY SHOW UP AT HIS OFFICE
TO THROW ONE OF HER OWN
POLYESTER UNIFORMS AT HIM, SHE
WOULD BE SO MAD.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT'S REALLY
GOING ON IN THIS WHOLE DEBATE.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T REALLY CARE
ALL THAT MUCH ABOUT THESE
ILLEGAL WORKERS, AS MUCH AS THEY
CARE ABOUT GETTING THEIR POWER
BACK.
WHAT DO I MEAN?
WE KNOW A LOT OF MIDDLE-CLASS
VOTERS ARE FED UP WITH THE
DEMOCRATS.
THE PARTY HAS TO BEGIN TO REMAKE
THE ELECTORATE.
HIS STATEMENT IGNORES THE FACT
THAT THE INFLOW OF ALL THE CHEAP
IMMIGRANT LABOR HURTS AMERICANS.
WHO ACTUALLY WILL DO THOSE JOBS
THAT HE TURNS HIS NOSE UP AT.
HERE'S HOW MY RADIO COLORS
REACTED TO HIS COMMENTS TODAY.
>> I WAS IN A POSITION WHERE I
DESPERATELY NEEDED A JOB.
I WENT AROUND TO THESE LOCATIONS
THAT SAID WERE ONLY HISPANICS IN
THE RESTAURANTS, I COULDN'T GET
MY FOOT IN THE DOOR.
>> I HAVE 38 YEARS EXPERIENCE
FOR HEAVY DEMOLITION, I GOT
TURNED DOWN FOR THREE JOBS
BECAUSE I DON'T SPEAK SPANISH.
>> Laura: FOR A FAIR WAGE,
AMERICANS WILL DO AND HAVE DONE
THESE JOBS, SENATOR DURBIN --
STOP LYING TO US.
PRESERVING ENTRY-LEVEL WORK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AMERICANS IS
IMPORTANT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE, IT'S
ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THOSE
WHO DON'T HAVE A COLLEGE DEGREE,
MAY BE FOR THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE
A SPECIAL SKILL SET.
I THINK IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
TO LOOK BACK, TO SEE HOW THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE SHIFTED ON THE
IMMIGRATION ISSUE.
I REMEMBER THE TIME WHEN
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY SUPPORTED THE
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
COUNTRY, THEY WORRIED ABOUT
FLOODING THE NATION WITH POOR
PEOPLE FROM OTHER COUNTRIES WHO
ARE GOING TO COMPETE WITH POOR
PEOPLE ALREADY IN OUR COUNTRY
WHO ARE AMERICAN CITIZENS OR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
25 YEARS AGO, THIS WAS DIANNE
FEINSTEIN.
>> MEXICO DOES NOTHING TO
ENFORCE ITS BORDERS.
IT IS MY VIEW THAT IF WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A NORTH AMERICAN
FREE TRADE AGREEMENT, MEXICO
MUST DO ITS SHARE.
TODAY AMERICA COULD BE THE
WELFARE SYSTEM.
THE PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE HERE
HAVE COME LEGALLY AT THIS TIME.
>> Laura: WHAT HAPPENED TO
THAT DIANE'S         DIANNE FEIS
THAT DIANE'S         DIANNE FEIE
THAT DIANE'S         DIANNE FEIN
THAT DIANE'S         DIANNE FEI.
IMAGINE IF A REPUBLICAN MADE
THAT COMMENT TODAY.
THERE WOULD BE HOWELLS FOR THE
LAME STREAM MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS,
HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT?
THIS IS BERNIE SANDERS 11 YEARS
AGO WHO SPOKE OUT AND VOTED
AGAINST GEORGE W. BUSH'S PUSH
FOR AMNESTY.
>> I THINK IT'S HIGH TIME THAT
THE SENATE OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA BEGAN TO STAND FOR
THE AMERICAN WORKER AND I WOULD
HOPE BEFORE AN IMMIGRATION BILL
IS PASSED THAT IT WOULD RESPECT
THE WHITES OF AMERICAN WORKERS
AND PROFESSIONAL WORKERS.
>> Laura: SANDERS IS RIGHT,
WHERE IS THE CONGRESSIONAL
CONCERN FOR THE HUMAN DIGNITY OF
AMERICA'S LOW SKILLED WORKERS
TODAY.
THEY CALL THEM THE WORKING POOR,
PEOPLE CAN SUPPORT FAMILIES ON
THESE JOBS.
THEY CAN LIVE DECENT LIVES.
IN CERTAIN LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES, IN PARTICULAR
INDUSTRIES, GUEST WORKERS DO
MAKE SENSE.
IT SHOULDN'T BECOME THE NORM, IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS AS
WELL.
IT'S JUST ONCE IN A BLUE MOON WE
HEARD SOMEBODY LIKE A SENATOR
SENATOR DURBIN SPEAK IN SUCH
EMOTIONAL TERMS ABOUT INNOCENT
AMERICANS WHO LOST THEIR JOBS OR
THEIR LIVES AT THE HANDS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
CASE IN POINT -- ON SUNDAY, AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT SLAMMED INTO
AN AMBULANCE CARRYING A MOTHER
AND HER 3-YEAR-OLD BOY IN
WINSTON-SALEM.
ALCOHOL BLOOD LEVEL WAS DOUBLE
THE LEGAL LIMIT.
HE INJURED THE MOTHER AND THE
DRIVER AND THE LITTLE BOY IS
DEAD.
HOW MANY INNOCENT LIVES HAVE TO
BE LOST BEFORE THE U.S. CONGRESS
FOCUSES ON THE WELL-BEING OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS RATHER THAN KOWTOWING
TO THE BUSINESS LOBBY?
WE ARE ALL WAITING.
DICK DURBIN HAS A JOB THAT CAN'T
BE TAKEN BY AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
MAYBE HE NEEDS A TASTE OF HIS
OWN MEDICINE THERE.
IF IT ENDS UP BEING A DEAL AT
ALL, THE NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN